frente a este edificio de la Universidad
de Nueva Delhi alrededor de 40 personas
se manifiestan contra una decisión
tomada por su administración la
prohibición de comer comida que no sea
vegetariana
[Música]
desde hace un año la carne está
prohibida en el comedor Y en el
internado la dirección Afirma basarse en
una encuesta realizada por esta según la
cual el 90% de los alumnos de este
campus son vegetarianos una cifra que
refuta el sindicato que inició la
manifestación
y se hace Llamar Una institución pública
cómo puede ser una institución pública
si no puede recibir al público en
absoluto la mayoría de la población
India no es vegetariana Por qué intentan
imponernos el vegetarianismo los
manifestantes fueron detenidos por la
policía la dirección no quiso responder
a nuestras preguntas en India las
medidas contra el consumo de carne se
han multiplicado desde que el Primer
Ministro narendra modi llegó al poder en
2014 desde el cierre de mataderos Hasta
el endurecimiento de las penas de cárcel
si se mata a una vaca los extremistas
hindúes lideran esta ola de nacionalismo
vegetariano en las afueras de Nueva de
élite se encuentra la ciudad comercial
de burgaon aquí mohamedrés ha trabajado
como carnicero Desde hace dos décadas
pero desde hace un año tiene que cerrar
su negocio todos los martes la razón es
que en el hinduismo este día se
considera sagrado por lo tanto la venta
de carne debe estar prohibido la
proviene del estado de haryana gobernado
por el bjp el partido del Primer
Ministro
una vez abrió un martes vinieron las
autoridades y nos quitaron los
utensilios como cuchillos agujas y
picadoras se llevaron unos 20 artículos
y nos pidieron que pagáramos seis euros
por cada utensilio se fueron y nos
advirtieron que si volvían a ver las
tiendas abiertas el martes la cerrarían
también dijeron que nos retirarían la
licencia
cerrar los martes para Mohamed significa
una pérdida de ingresos de casi 150
euros mensuales según él la prohibición
tiene como principal objetivo de
estigmatizar a su comunidad carguemos la
mayoría de los carniceros somos
musulmanes nosotros administramos los
mataderos si cierran nuestros negocios
es un claro ataque en nuestra contra
esta obsesión contra la comida no
vegetariana es parte de un discurso más
amplio de los fundamentalistas hindúes
que consideran el consumo de carne como
algo contrario a la identidad
a 20 kilómetros de la carnicería de
Mohamed un grupo de hombres se está
preparando para llevar a cabo una
operación en medio de la noche mono
humanizar es el jefe de los aquí
llamados
en español dos veces a la semana monóu y
sus hombres detienen y registran los
vehículos que podrían transportar vacas
en esta carretera nuestro informante nos
dijo que hoy llegará un camión de 10
ruedas lleno de vacas
los musulmanes llevan las vacas amehuar
y las sacrifican una operación llevada a
cabo de forma ilegal y tolerada por las
fuerzas del orden los gaura son una
milicia Armada cuyos números se ha
disparado desde 2014 se estima son Diez
mil en toda India
Los Defensores de las vacas tienen en la
mira a una comunidad en particular
hemos Atrapado a unas 2.000 3.000
personas carniceros que sacrificaban
vacas y vendían su carne la mayoría de
las personas detenidas eran musulmanas
tenemos que proteger a las vacas porque
está ligado a nuestra religión es
importante convertirse en un soldado de
la vaca y yo diría que todo el mundo
debería convertirse en un soldado de la
vaca Porque si se salvan las vacas se
salvará el país y se salvará nuestra
región mono no oculta sus acciones
violentas publica sus hazañas en las
redes sociales
el hombre se muestra con sus armas
[Música]
y también con policías y miembros del
partido gobernante
[Música]
unas semanas después de nuestra
grabación mono y otros gauratchak fueron
acusados de secuestrar y matar a dos
musulmanes porque estaban Implicados En
el tráfico de vacas sus cuerpos fueron
encontrados calcinados en un vehículo
desde entonces en el pueblo natal de
nacer y junaid las dos víctimas los
llamamientos para que mono humanizar sea
detenido se multipliquen
pertenece a una organización de jóvenes
fundamentalistas hindúes
esa organización fue creada por el bjp
y desde que el bjp la creó los
asesinatos No cesan
ahora me da mucho miedo vivir en India
por Cómo mataron a mis hermanos
siento que me van a asesinar si salgo de
mi casa y que me van a matar a hachazos
como a otros musulmanes
por el momento la policía ha
identificado a ocho sospechosos de haber
participado en este crimen mono
humanizar sigue declarando se inocente
según un conteo de Human right watch
publicado a finales de 2019 al menos 44
personas han sido asesinadas por los
gaura chat desde 2015
36 de las cuales eran musulmanes